[ MUSIC PLAYING ]
- I need you to know something.
What happened before,
the girl who did that --
I don't even recognize.
- The story totally revolves around Sophie.
And we've always said that she's the investigator,
but she's also the investigation.
Like, who was she, really?
- When we first meet Sophie,
she's in quite a vulnerable state.
She's had to be placed
under a conservatorship,
by her husband James.
- Just trying to do the right thing.
- I know, but,
I'm better now.
James hasn't said an awful lot
about the accident to her.
For him, it's a chance
for their whole relationship to start fresh.
To have a lead character who
really doesn't know who she is,
and who really has to go on
a journey of rediscovery,
it makes her incredibly easy to identify with.
- Sophie appears to be this very demure,
traditional, good wife, but something about that
rings hollow to her from the beginning.
- Stepping into the outside world,
raises more questions than answers,
in terms of what she's been led to believe her life was.
- Sophie.
- Im sorry, do I know you?
- We need to talk.
- To be stripped of the pieces of your past
that make you who you are
and then to be told who you are
by people around you,
that becomes very interesting.
- Sophie is an incredibly complex,
compelling character,
and what unfolds in the show is unlike anything
audiences have seen before.
- Take a mark.
- Action.
- Tell me who you are, right now.
- Gugu is a spectacular actress,
and in this role, she has a challenge of
not just being the Sophie that we meet in the pilot,
but being all the different versions of Sophie.
Gugu plays the character in such an engaging way,
the character is so sympathetic because,
in a very sort of, real way, it pulls apart
what happens if you're not who you really are.
- There are depths to her that will go places
that I think are really going to surprise people.
- People are going to be really asking the question,
what would you do in Sophie's situation,
if you really didn't know any of your own secrets?
I hope people really enjoy the ride.
[ MUSIC PLAYING ]